[soft organ music]
♪ ♪
- Hey, babe.
- Hey.
- How you doing?
- I'm holding up.
- Hang in there, dum-dum.
Love you.
- Guys, this is Elwood.
He was Lois' husband.
- Oh, we're so sorry for your
loss. We loved Lois very much.
- Damn emphysema.
If only I told her not
to smoke that last cigarette.
- I don't think it was the
last cigarette that did it.
[whispered]
Plus she ate like shit.
- Tim!
- Let us know if
you ever need anything.
Someone to hang out with
or just someone to talk to.
- Tomorrow.
- Huh?
- Well, let's
hang out tomorrow.
- Okay.
Yeah, that'll be nice.
- Oh!
- Oh, no!
- What in the world?
- Move on! This was her final
wish. We respected it.
Now just move on!
- Ohh.
- So waxy.
She looks lovely.
- Thank you.
both: Whoa!